>> Tucker: WELL, GOOD
EVENING.
WELCOME TO TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT.
YOU MAY HAVE HEARD THAT ABC
CANCELLED ITS MOST POPULAR
SCRIPTED SHOW YESTERDAY
AFTER A LEAD ACTOR SENT OUT
A SERIES OF BIZARRE TWEETS
WHICH SHE LATER BLAMED ON
SLEEPING PILLS.
YOU'VE READ ABOUT IT BUT
THERE IS AT LEAST ONE UPSIDE
TO THE ROSEANNE STORY.
THE LEFT IS ON THE RECORD
OPPOSING RACISM.
ATTACKING PEOPLE ON THE
BASIS OF THEIR RACE, THEY
ARE TELLING US, AND OF
COURSE THEY ARE ABSOLUTELY
RIGHT ABOUT THAT.
LET'S HOPE THIS CONVERSATION
CONTINUES AND PROGRESSES.
LIBERALS MAY FINALLY CONCEDE
THAT DISCRIMINATION BASED ON
SKIN COLOR REALLY IS WRONG
WHETHER IT'S IN HIRING OR
PROMOTIONS OR GOVERNMENT
CONTRACTING OR SCHOOL
ADMISSION.
THEY ADMIT THAT, THAT WOULD
BE REAL PROGRESS.
IT'S NOT HAPPENING YET
THOUGH.
FOR NOW AMERICAN LIBERALS
ARE STILL LIVING IN THAT
STRANGE IRONY-FREE WORLD
WHERE IT'S POSSIBLE TO
DENOUNCE RACISM EVEN AS YOU
COMMIT IT.
THAT'S THE SAME WORLD AL
GORE OCCUPIES WHEN HE FLIES
PRIVATE SUCCESS JETS TO
GLOBAL WARMING CONFERENCES.
IT'S THE PLACE WHERE
ATTORNEYS GENERAL CAN YELL
AT YOU ABOUT DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE EVEN AS THEY BEAT
UP THEIR GIRLFRIEND.
IT'S HYPOCRISY LAND.
IT'S WHERE LIBERALS LIVE.
LAST NIGHT, FOR EXAMPLE,
MSNBC HELD A TOWN HALL
MEETING DEDICATED TO
FIGHTING RACISM.
GUESS WHO THEY INVITED TO
LECTURE AMERICA ON THE
TOPIC?
YOU GUESSED IT, RACISTS.
THE SPECIAL WAS LITERALLY
CO-HOSTED BY AL SHARPTON,
REMEMBER HIM?
HE IS THE GUY WHO RIDICULED
JEWS IN NEW YORK AS, QUOTE.
DIAMOND DEALERS.
HE IS THE ONE WHO DENOUNCED
A JEWISH STORE OWNER AS A
WHITE INTERLOPER.
THAT INSTA
THAT INSTIGATED A RACIAL
MASSACRE IN WHICH 8 PEOPLE
WERE MURDERED.
ALSO ON STAGE LAST NIGHT WAS
A GUY CALLED TIM WISE.
WISE DESCRIBES HIMSELF AS
PROFESSIONAL ANTIRACISM
ACTIVISTS WHICH OUGHT TO BE
A TIPOFF THAT HE HIMSELF IS
A RACIST, WHICH OBVIOUSLY HE
IS.
HERE IS WISE USING MSNBC'S
PLATFORM TO MAKE UGLY
GENERALIZATIONS BASED ON
SKIN COLOR.
>> WHITE AMERICA HAS BEEN
RAISED TO BELIEF A, THE
POLICE IS ALWAYS THE GOOD
GUYS AND FRANKLY THAT BLACK
LIVES MATTER LESS THAN WHITE
COMFORT.
WHAT YOU ARE SAYING IS MY
DISCOMFORT WITH YOU RIGHT
NOW IS WORTH MORE THAN THE
POTENTIAL THAT YOUR LIFE
COULD BE SNUFFED IN 10
MINUTES.
>> Tucker: ISN'T THAT
SLANDER AGAINST AN ENTIRE
RACIAL CATEGORY?
OH, YES, IT IS.
BUT LET'S SAY YOU WANT EVEN
MORE NASTY RACIAL
STEREOTYPING.
MSNBC IS THE CHANNEL FOR
YOU.
THEY'VE GOT IT HERE IS TIM
WISE AGAIN.
KEEP IN MIND, THIS IS WHAT
LIBERALS ARE NOW CLAIMING IS
THE OPPOSITE OF RACISM.
>> THE GENTRIFIERS OF TODAY.
THEIR PARENTS OR
GRANDPARENTS RAN AWAY FROM
THE CITY TO GET AWAY FROM
BLACK AND BROWN FOLK.
AND NOW THEIR CHILDREN AND
THEIR GRANDCHILDREN ARE
SAYING, OH, THE SUBURBS,
THERE IS SO MANY OLIVE
GARDENS I CAN GO TO.
I NEED TO GO BACK TO THE
CITY AND GET MY LIFE IN THE
CITY.
WHEN I DO THAT I NEED TO
HAVE MY HOT YOGA STUDIO AND
BY PORTER STUDIO AND MY
STUFF REPRESENTED.
IF YOU INTRUDE ON THAT, I
WILL THEN CALL THE POLICE.
>> Tucker: ARE YOU TAKING
NOTES ON THIS?
ARE YOU GETTING THIS?
THEY ARE TELLING YOU ON
MSNBC THAT BECAUSE CERTAIN
PEOPLE HAVE THE SAME SKIN
COLOR THEY ALL HAVE THE SAME
DUMB ATTITUDES.
THEY LIKE THE SAME CRAPPY
RESTAURANT.
THEY SPEND THEIR FREE TIME
PURSUING THE SAME FRIVOLOUS
WHO AREYS.
THEY ARE BY THE WAY EVERY
ONE OF THEM IMMORAL.
CAN YOU TELL BY THE WAY THEY
LOOK.
THAT'S THE OFFICIAL POSITION
OF THE PERSONAL LEFT, THE
SAME PEOPLE CURRENTLY
ACCUSING YOU OF RACISM.
HUH?
CHRISTOPHER HARRIS EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF UNHYPHENATED
AMERICA AND HE JOINS US
TONIGHT.
MR. HARRIS, WHAT DO YOU MAKE
OF THAT, WATCHING THAT?
>> TUCKER, THERE IS A LOT OF
THINGS GOING ON IN THE WORLD
RIGHT NOW THAT CAME TO MY
MIND, FOR EXAMPLE, WHAT'S
HAPPENING IN VENEZUELA.
WHEN TIM WAS TALKING ABOUT
PEOPLE TRYING TO GENTRIFY
AREAS.
WELL, IF YOU LOOK IN
VENEZUELA RIGHT NOW, THERE
ARE PEOPLE FLEEING A
TERRIBLE GEOPOLITICAL
SOCIOECONOMIC ISSUE.
AND THEY ARE GOING TO
TRINIDAD.
>> Tucker: RIGHT.
>> THEY HAVE INFLUX IN
TRINIDAD OF VENEZUELANS.
AND TRINIDAD IS TRYING TO
IMPLEMENT RULES TO KIND OF
PUSH SOME OF THEM OUT.
NOW, MOST PEOPLE DON'T KNOW
THERE IS A LOT OF BLACK
PEOPLE IN VENEZUELA.
THEY DON'T ALL LOOK LIKE
HUGO CHAVEZ.
IN FACT, SOUTH AMERICA HAS
ONE OF THE LARGEST
PERCENTAGES, OVER 50% OF THE
SLAVES TAKEN FROM AFRICA
WERE BROUGHT TO SOUTH
AMERICA TO PLACES LIKE
BRAZIL AND VENEZUELA AND
PLACES LIKE THAT.
HERE IT IS YOU HAVE PEOPLE
WHO ARE BLACK WHO DON'T WANT
OTHER PEOPLE WHO ARE BLACK
FLOODING INTO THEIR COUNTRY.
>> Tucker: MAYBE IT'S MORE
AN ECONOMIC ISSUE AND I
THINK, BY THE WAY, THERE ARE
FAIR QUESTIONS TO RAISE
ABOUT RADICAL DEMOGRAPHIC
CHANGE FOR SURE.
IT UPSETS PEOPLE.
AND I UNDERSTAND THAT.  BUT,
TO PRETEND THAT IT'S ALL
ABOUT RACE AND THAT ONE RACE
IS WORSE THAN ANOTHER RACE,
ISN'T THAT THE DEFINITION OF
RACISM?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
TIM WISE IS GOING TO BE ABLE
TO PAY HIS RENT THIS MONTH
BECAUSE HE IS A RACIAL PIMP.
THAT'S WHAT HE IS THAT'S
WHAT HE DOES.
HE TRAVELS AROUND THE
COUNTRY GOING TO COLLEGES,
TELLING YOUNG WHITE MEN AND
YOUNG WHITE WOMAN THAT YOU
ARE A RACIST AND THAT YOU
ARE A BENEFIT OF WHITE
PRIVILEGE AND THEY GO ON AND
THEY TELL THEIR PARENTS HOW
TERRIBLE THEY ARE BECAUSE A
GUY NAMED TIM WISE CAME TO
MY COLLEGE AND TOLD ME I
HAVE WHITE PRIVILEGE.
AND ESSENTIALLY WHAT TIM IS
DOING, HE IS ASSUMING A
PRIVILEGE THAT, QUITE
FRANKLY, I DON'T ACKNOWLEDGE
THAT HE HAS.
I HAVE ZERO SENSE OF
INFERIORITY.
THAT'S ONE OF THOSE THINGS
THAT SOMEONE LIKE TIM WANTS
ME TO BELIEVE.
IN FACT,.
>> Tucker: YOU THINK HE
WANTS YOU TO HAVE A SENSE OF
INFERIORITY?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
PRESIDENT BUSH TALKED ABOUT
IT HE SAID IT'S THE SOFT
BIGOTRY OF LOW EXPECTATION.
>> Tucker: YEAH.
>> THAT'S WHAT'S HAPPENING
AROUND THE WORLD AND WHAT'S
HAPPENING IN AMERICA.
THEY ARE CONSTANTLY TRYING
TO TELL YOUNG BLACK MEN AND
YOUNG BLACK WOMEN HAVE YOU
NO CHANCE IN AMERICA BECAUSE
OF YOUR PIGMENTATION.
NO ONE WANTS TO TALK ABOUT
THE FACT THAT DIFFERENT
DEMOGRAPHICS.
ALL BLACK PEOPLE ARE NOT
AFRICAN-AMERICANS.
MY WIFE IS ACTUALLY HER
PARENTS ARE FROM PANAMA.
HER PARENTS CAME HERE
LEGALLY WITH NOTHING.
THEY WERE ABLE TO CLIMB THE
SOCIOECONOMIC LADDER.
BOTH OF THEM OBTAINED THEIR
DEGREES.
BOTH THEIR DAUGHTERS
OBTAINED THEIR DEGREES.
YET, THERE ARE PEOPLE WHO
ARE, I GUESS SOME WOULD CALL
ME AN AMERICAN.
I DON'T ANSWER TO THAT TERM.
I'M AN AMERICAN BLACK
PERSON.
OBVIOUSLY CAN YOU TELL BY MY
PIGMENTATION I'M BLACK.
BUT THERE IS LOTS OF PEOPLE
EVEN IN MY EXTENDED FAMILY
WHO HAVE NOT ATTAINED WHAT
SOME OF MY IN-LAWS HAVE
OBTAINED REGARDLESS OF THE
COLOR OF THEIR SKIN.
BUT TIM WISE WOULD YOU HAVE
TO BELIEVE THAT SIMPLY
BECAUSE OF THE COLOR OF YOUR
SKIN YOU CAN'T BE SUCCESSFUL
IN AMERICA.
AND DO YOU KNOW WHAT?
PRESIDENT TRUMP, GOD BLESS
HIM, WHAT HE IS DOING WITH
THE ECONOMY RIGHT NOW, IT'S
HELPING BLACK PEOPLE.
>> Tucker: WHERE DO YOU
THINK A COUNTRY WINDS UP
WHERE THE OFFICIAL POSITION
IS THAT THE RACES ARE
DIFFERENT, SOME ARE MORE
MORAL THAN OTHERS.
AND BASICALLY, THEY SHOULD
HATE EACH OTHER?
THAT IS THE MESSAGE THAT A
LOT OF OUR ELITES ARE FOIS
TING ON THE REST OF US.
THEY MAKE THEIR MONEY BY
TEARING PEOPLE APART.
UNHYPHENATED AMERICA WHAT IS
UNHYPHENATED AMERICA?
IT'S WHAT IT SOUNDS LIKE.
IF YOU BELIEVE IF YOU
EMBRACE IF YOU PROMOTE THE
PRINCIPLES OF LIFE, LIBERTY,
AND THE PURSUIT OF
HAPPINESS.
THEN YOU ARE AN AMERICAN.
AND THERE IS NO NEED FOR ANY
PREFIX OR SUFFIX.
YOU ARE JUST AN AMERICAN.
THAT'S WHAT NEEDS TO BE
PREACHED AND TAUGHT ON OUR
COLLEGE CAMPUSES INSTEAD OF
HAVING THE TIM WISES AND AL
SHARPTONS.
>> Tucker: WHEN I WAS A KID.
I'M 49.
NOT THAT OLD.